how does a character go from here
to here
but maybe this isn't even the correct
question to ask here
because bad guy going good is not
exactly a revolutionary trope in
storytelling
so maybe the better question to ask here
is
why killua's complete change of
character feels so incredibly authentic
and natural and why his story is so
strongly relatable
there's a reason why killua zaldik is by
far
the most beloved character in the story
that
yoshihiro togashi has filled to the brim
with
fascinatingly complex and intriguing
characters
being cool charismatic and at times even
a bit creepy
kilowa is already a through and through
enjoyable character
even just at the superficial level and
being the second protagonist of the
story
we accompany him on his journey with
gone through the dangerous world of
hunter hunter
and enjoy watching him grow stronger and
more mature
a typical shonen adventure
but as is the case with almost all
characters in this beautifully crafted
series
you have to dig just a tiny bit deeper
into the structure of the plot
to discover that kiloa's character is
pretty much
as complex and multi-layered as it gets
hilua's arc contains a number of
underlying themes that i think are all
worth looking at in detail
to truly understand his character this
includes his quest to break free from
the chains of his family
developing self-worth seeking freedom of
will
and ultimately finding his purpose in
life
all elements that togashi has not only
connected to the plot at hand and
kilowatt's journey through the world
but that he also has interconnected and
woven into each other to
form a complete and organic feeling
character that is shaped by his
upbringing
but also his environments as we've
discussed in the last video
the overall theme of hunter hunter is
humanity
and what it means to be human in a
superhuman world
and togashi uses the classic trope of
the body story to contrast both kilua
and
gon and their growth and coming of age
from a realistic
and credible perspective
thus instead of going chronologically
which might feel a bit too much like a
recap of the story
i think it's best to look at the
relationship between kilo and gone first
to give you a better idea of the overall
character
and then delve deeper into the details
of his character arc
before we can discuss the dreadfully
dramatic dream team that is kilo and
gone however
i believe that we first have to take a
closer look at hilo's upbringings
to really understand how he became the
unsettlingly
dark boy that we first meet during the
hunter exam
killua's tragic childhood and the
complex relations within his family
are something that is revealed only in
increments by togashi while we travel
from arc to arc
while we personally get to see his
family home and parts of his relatives
in the zaldik family arc after the
hunter exam
many crucial details surrounding the
family are revealed in other arcs
hilua's relationship with ilumi for
instance is introduced during the hunter
exam arc
his grandfather appears for the very
first time in the york new arc to take
out chrolo
and aluka is only introduced after the
chimera antarct
and so if you sometimes feel a bit
confused by all the different
relationships and connections within the
zaldik family
first of all you're not alone but
secondly this seems to have been done on
purpose
as this panel here illustrates pretty
well i think
now this incremental introduction of
kilos family and
all its members serves two larger
purposes i believe
firstly next to killua several of the
zoldics
generally play a relevant role in
several story arcs and seem to be a
major force in the world
politically and militarily and secondly
and maybe more importantly i think
togashi slowly shares
more and more information about kiloa's
past and true personality
as an essential part of his character
arc and development
which we'll be discussing in a second
overall there are four major themes in
kiloua's past
that make him the inhuman person that we
meet at the beginning of the story
and that he needs to overcome throughout
his journey with gone
assassination torture expectations
and love so let's look at each of these
elements
in a bit more detail
as the zoltics are a family of assassins
violence and murder are not only part of
their daily business
but of their family identity kiluah was
trained and shaped to become a top tier
assassin
basically from the moment that he was
born
growing up in this kind of environment
kilua has grown
numb to the act of killing to the point
where he even seems to be getting a bit
of enjoyment out of it
we can see this for instance in chapter
14 during the hunter exam arc
where he grows frustrated playing ball
with natero and gone
at some point he relies more and more on
excessive force
resulting in a kick that in natora's
words would be capable of shattering a
normal person's leg
and so after leaving the game in the
bloodlust that has started to overtake
him throughout the match
he releases his frustration on some
unfortunate hunter examinees that cross
his path
leaving them dead on the ground as
kiluah walks away
without so much as a second glance at
them thus
his upbringing has left him with little
regard for the value of life
and the use of violence against others
now as part of his training and due to
the high expectations in him
kilua was also subjected to countless
tortures by the hand of his own family
when he was young
as a result he became immune to poison
developed a high tolerance to
electricity
and grew in agility and strength with
his fingernails being able to turn into
sharp claws
but the cruel physical abuse clearly has
left some strong marks on him
physically and mentally while kilua does
in fact try his best to conceal any
signs of the torture and cruelty he had
to endure all his life
slowly but steadily we learn more and
more about the horrors he must have had
to endure
from ilumi's manipulation to the scars
he carries on his body that we can
clearly see during his training with
biscuit
we finally understand that the horrible
insights we got into kilowatt's
childhood in the family house
were apparently only the tip of the
iceberg
here we actually get a first glimpse
into this when miloki
is attempting to torture killua after
running off to take the hunter exam
the fact that he was brutally tortured
at the hand of his own brother
didn't seem to bother him at all neither
physically
nor mentally however while kilua might
have grown numb to his own abuse
he seems to clearly understand that what
has happened to him
was and is terrible because once he
learned that gon leorio and karapika had
come for him the very notion that his
friends could be threatened
placed kilua in an immediately
aggressive disposition
where he appeared more than willing to
attack his own brother
something that miloki seemed to
immediately pick up upon himself
given his troubled expression here
and while this is only one example out
of many it already does offer us our
first implication of kilua's cripplingly
perverted sense of self-worth having
known nothing
else in his entire life kiluah didn't
mind being tortured
almost as if he felt that for him to
experience this was only
natural and entirely acceptable and yet
he was completely enraged at the thought
that someone else he cared about
might have had to endure this very same
treatment
so his relationship to torture is not
only a strong indicator of killua's lack
of self-worth
but also gives us a first insight that
despite his cruel past
he still has a natural sense of morality
that lies suppressed under his numbness
something that i think his family
without any doubt wish to get rid of
now on top of everything his family did
to him or maybe
exactly because of it kilowatt also
suffers under the heavy expectations
that his parents have in him for
becoming the heir to the family legacy
the zaldiks are infamous in the hunter
world for being top tier assassins
with some of the most capable fighters
in the story
and yet within this group of monsters it
was kilua
that was chosen to one day take over the
family
because he showed the most potential out
of all his siblings
including his brother elomi but despite
being a true prodigy
in terms of fighting and mastering new
skills something that he demonstrates
over and over again side by side with
gone
hilua has no interest whatsoever
in continuing the family business which
i think is quite understandable
given how his family has treated him and
it's one of the reasons that killua is
looking for his
own purpose in life and makes us readers
wonder
whether or not he actually has a free
will of his own
and this already brings me to the last
theme of kilo's childhood
love
as we will see again later on in this
video expressing affection and love
is something that killua is struggling
with throughout the story
and it's something that he has to learn
more about first
throughout large parts of it killua only
knows how to show his love for others by
protecting them
for instance he tries to protect gone
countless times during their journey
and was reduced to tears at the thought
of failing
he stood up for zushi and he even
initiated his friendship with ikalgo
by saving his life only to name a few
examples
his inexperience with expressing such
emotions comes from the
twisted sense of love that he's
experienced from mostly his mother kikio
and his brother ilomi kikio was willing
to literally
chain kilua down and beat him if it
meant keeping him
quote unquote safe at least in her eyes
illumi meanwhile in his overprotective
and almost psychopathic way
went so far as to implant one of his
manipulative nan needles in tequila
without his knowledge or consent giving
him subconscious orders that dictated
his actions throughout most of the
series
both of their abusive shows of affection
for kilua
have most likely accompanied him all his
life and
based on nothing but his own innate
sense of morality
protecting was the only thing he really
knew how to do
and so these four elements assassination
torture expectations and love
are what i believe have made kilua the
physically strong
but emotionally broken kit that gone
first meets at the hunter entrance exam
and i think that the zaldik family home
does a wonderful job of
symbolizing all this
the inside of the house is more akin to
a medieval castle
decked out with a modern security system
a torture room
and even a secret room to hide a sister
being on top of a mountain it's quite
isolated and because of the numerous
safeguards and obstacles that separate
outsiders from the family
starting with the testing gate it's also
easy to see
why kilwa never had any friends until he
met gone
assassin's training and due this aside
making it painfully clear
why kilua wanted to break free from his
family so badly
based on the theme of humanity and the
realistic approach that hunter hunter
takes on people
it is only understandable then that
killua ended up with such a dark
twisted and insecure perspective after
experiencing so much
physical and emotional abuse and so i
think it's
more than fair to say that the zaldik
family is the main source of kilua's
need
for finding free will self-worth and a
purpose in life
and so now that we know this underlying
psychological background
let's now look at what happened when
togashi threw this
character into the hunter worlds and
what better place to start
than the most important relationship in
the story
his friendship with gone
we already talked a little bit about the
relationship between gon and killua in
the last video
however i purposefully decided to save
the majority of it for today
since i think we need some understanding
of both kilua and gone
so we can truly understand and
appreciate that connection in full
the main thing i think that makes the
friendship between them so
special is that they have completely
mirrored character arcs
one negative and the other positive
gon goes from joyful and caring at the
beginning of the story
to numb cruel and inhuman towards the
end
killua meanwhile goes from numb cruel
and inhuman to joyful and
caring and so while gone's lowest point
is close towards the end of the story in
his brutal bird of pitot
hilo's lowest point in the story is
pretty close towards the beginning
at the end of the hunter exam first as
we already mentioned
he kills off some of the other hunter
examinees simply out of annoyance and
bloodlust
and later during the final stage he ends
up failing the hunter exam overall
for killing another contender
manipulated by illumi and being
recaptured by the claws of his family
he leaves behind gone and goes back home
with his will and dreams
once again broken this state of complete
surrender to his family
and the cruel act of murder he commits
are the absolute
bottom point for kilua in the entire
series
and from this point forward his arc is
on a constant incline
ironically enough it was actually gone's
friendship and original morality
that saved kiluah and gone's later moral
decline
encourages him to question his own
morality and views
both gon and kilua had to grow up with
no friends around them
and both of them want to travel the
world and become stronger
thus the hunter exam was the perfect arc
format to quickly establish a friendship
between these two characters
right at the start of the story in a
very believable way
since both of them were the youngest
contenders in a contest meant for adults
they naturally found each other while at
the same time highlighting their
uniqueness
however while gone immediately sees kilo
as his friend
given his past and low sense of
self-worth kilua seems to feel like he
has to earn gone's friendship first
thus during the final examination he
reveals that all he really wants is
forgotten to be his friends
without realizing that it's a not
something he needs to ask for
and b that gone already considers him
his best friend at this point
and even though leorio tells him that he
already is gone's friends
under the influence of his brother
kilua's spirit breaks
and he sees his dream being crushed in
the despair
that overtakes him in his brother's
presence he apparently defaults to the
only thing he'd ever known in his life
and he kills botero in cold bloods
without gone there to stop him
ultimately returning home certain that
he
after all has no will of his own
and when kilua is literally chained up
again inside his family house
it once again is gone who comes to save
him
and takes him out into the worlds
showing kilua that he now
truly has made a real friend gone
is kilua's light in the dark something
that he makes
very clear in this moment here
this is probably one of my favorite
scenes in the story
it brings us back to the start of the
adventure before going into the dark
part of the chimera and arc
it's just one of many moments where
kilua finds himself the most
worthless person in the world all while
believing that gone would be able to
lead him to a better life
and throughout the story gone does
exactly that he teaches kilua how to
engage in healthy interactions with
other people
how to express love in different ways
and he offers him a motivation for
self-improvement
it was this motivation that led kilua to
master nen and hatsu
to the incredible degree he has and
ultimately to remove the needle planted
in him by ilumi
finally allowing his true personality to
shine through
and so despite his creeping decline into
darkness
for the kid who came from darkness in
the first place
gone indeed served as a light to help
kilua navigate his own
and turn on his inner light switch
and ultimately i think that kiloa really
seems to have learned from god's
influence
on himself of being a light to the
darkness
because towards the end we find that
kilua has now taken on the role
of being a light for aluka and so while
gone's character arc followed the path
of a tragedy
kilwa's much rather was a journey of
redemption
thus gone's falling character arc and
kilauea's rising one
slowly approach each other until they
finally cross paths during the greed
island arc
where i would argue both are roughly at
the same moral level
and the two boys are the closest and
most similar to each other
with the beginning of the chimera and
arc however we
see a rapid alienation between the two
gon's arc starts spiraling into darkness
while kiwas has a sudden uptake after
removing illumi's needle
and so during the arc gons and kilowa's
relationship reaches its climax
and so despite kilua's alien position to
the audience at the start of the series
as a young assassin he quickly becomes a
far easier reference point than gone
he starts to see nuance in situations
where gon
only sees his own twisted sense of black
and white
and so killua is the one to save gon
from being killed by the chimera and
early in the arc
while gone fully unprepared throws
himself into combat in order to get
revenge for the death of his friends
finally liberated from illumi's
influence and with his newfound sense of
free will and independence
kilua begins to understand the complex
sense of justice and morality
that the world of hunter hunter operates
on and increasingly grows worried about
gon's
single-minded and inflexible approach
and so
when god is supposed to show his resolve
to morale he visualizes
all the hate and negative emotions
inside him to fuel a frightening attack
only in the last moment killua steps in
and manages to pull gun back from the
brink looking
seriously worried for his friends
later however as gon vows to kill the
innocent bystander komugi to get a shot
at pito for killing kite
kilua isn't able to reach his friend
anymore
because at this point gon doesn't
understand killua's true feelings
anymore
as he demonstrated so touchingly after
the hunter exam
and so when hilo finally reaches him and
pito
gon says this
we can see kilua visibly tensing up here
and being deeply hurt by god's words
and so once gun snaps and trades in his
remaining humanity for violence
kilua fully abandons his cruel past
but still is unable to do anything but
watch in horror
after saving gon's life both boys
finally decide to go their own ways
and it truly feels like something
significant has changed
it's a departure in every sense of the
word and so
when the lingering final shot of the two
opposing gungi pieces overlapping each
other
slowly fades away it feels almost
impossible to reconcile the beginning of
the show
with the end with both of them having
switched places
[Music]
i think by now we're starting to get a
pretty good idea of kilua and
what it is that drives his character
kilo's behavior and actions over the
course of their journey
are quite different from gods something
i think togashi
wonderfully explains through their nand
types
gone is an enhancer who are simple and
determined
most of them never lie hide nothing and
are very straightforward in their
actions or in their thinking
their words and actions are often
dominated by their feelings and they're
generally very selfish and focused on
their own goals
something that basically describes gone
pretty perfectly
the same i think goes for kilua being a
transmuter type
they are whimsical prone to deceit and
fickle
and many tend to hide their true
intentions this also fits killua pretty
well
after all who other than a whimsical
transmuter could be expected to spend
200 million jenny on snacks
additionally killa is not opposed to
lying
being the genuinely well-meaning person
that he is he
only lies when necessary as observed by
biski
yet he does lie nonetheless the most
notable trait here however
is his extreme inclination to conceal
information
as expressed near the end of the york
new arc hilua will choose to remain
ignorant rather than ask a question that
shows his ignorance to others
being grateful that gone asked the
questions he was so reluctant to
additionally despite admiring guns so
much
he tends to withhold most of his
feelings or thoughts for him
thus kilua is quickly embarrassed when
gon draws attention to their friendship
as the true value of their bond is
something that kilua prefers to keep for
himself
the finest example of this is the
heart-wrenching plea to pom
to help gon out of his dark mindset
according to the narrator
kiluah had intended to lie here as well
and conceal his true feelings
and yet in a moment of emotional
desperation let it slip
this short act of opening up was so
powerful for him that he simply couldn't
conceal anything in this moment
breaking down into tears and begging
also
since many transmuters rely on
techniques that give unique and
unpredictable properties to their nan
that reflect their personalities
something we'll also be exploring in the
next video in hisoka
i think killua's electricity powers are
also a wonderful representation of his
past
and growth at the same time and so i
think it's finally time to look at
kilo's character arc
and how his character has developed over
the course of the story
differently than gone kilua starts into
the story
without a clear desire or purpose his
original desire was to break free from
his family
and to find his own path and yet since
he manages to do so relatively early on
he then lacks any specific goal and thus
accompanies gone on his journey to find
his father
now that doesn't mean that kilua doesn't
have a drive though
as we've discussed before on a more
subconscious level
kilo's need is to break free from his
brother's control
to regain his free will find self-worth
and
ultimately a new purpose in life a
philosophy that by the way is called
ikigai in japanese
we've already discussed large parts of
the first half of the story
except for the york new arc where kilua
is prepared to sacrifice
himself so that gone can escape the
phantom troop but what i really want to
focus on however
is kilua's moment of revelation and the
climax of his arc
the emotional battle with the chimera
and ramets
seeing his friend being on the verge of
death kilo's will to save gone
comes into conflict with his brother's
orders to run away from any strong
opponent
and so after once again apologizing to
gone for not being of any use to him
the friendship and love that he's built
towards him overpower his brother's
powers
and he's able to remove the needle that
he wasn't even aware of until that very
point
the scene has some striking implications
for kilua
presents the moment of redemption and it
touches upon
all of the themes surrounding his
character are we slaves to our birth
to our genetics the way our families
brought us up or
the lack of a family or by sheer force
of will
and concentrated effort can we choose to
become something different than what we
were
and surpass the limitations set by our
upbringing
it's a very personal issue that
ultimately culminates into
one central question how much agency do
we actually have about our own lives
the needle suddenly gives us a whole lot
of answers about kilowatt's behavior
that have been haunting us the entire
series and i think finally realizing
that kilowatt was being controlled and
manipulated by ilumi
suddenly also makes his gruesome choice
to kill bodoro a bit more understandable
because i think in this moment killua
was simply feeling overwhelmed
confused and was struggling to overcome
this subconscious urge
while remaining faithful to his friends
and so i think
feeling caught by his brother and
uncertain of lyorio's own chances to
pass the exam
kiluah decided to give up his own
chances to become a hunter
to help leorio achieve his dream of
course his lack of self-worth
also played a role in this choice i
believe allowing all of his friends but
himself
to become a hunter and so it's not only
a very cathartic moment for us readers
but also for kilua himself to find out
that his fear and uselessness
was actually caused by ilomizhatsu and
not due to
his own cowardice as it turns out there
never was
anything wrong with killua in the first
place showing us that he was actually
the best friend anyone could ever wish
for being as
loyal and dependable in spite of the
literal mind control
trying to push him away and so i think
that this moment gives us an even deeper
insight into kilua's personality
in one regard it allows us to see just
how far
kilua will go for those he loves while
captured by the phantom troop surrounded
on all sides by some of the most
infamous
and dangerous nen users in the world
kilua still
instinctively began to intervene in
god's mistreatment until hizoga stopped
him
i think we can only imagine what kind of
pressure kiluah must have felt due to
the needle in this situation
and how many escape plans were running
through his mind
and yet he was ready to stand up for his
friend neat
for me this establishes kilua as one of
the most protective
caring and self-sacrificing characters
in
all of manga and what i find also
important to note here is that this
moment
is not the end for his character arc but
rather a start
that really enabled kilowatt to grow way
faster than before
actually steepening his arc even more in
the events that follow the scene we see
kilua stand up to the royal guard
chase down gone challenge his family
protect aluka
and see to god's healing a true snowball
effect of greater and greater displays
of determination
intelligence and loyalty only made
possible by allowing kilua
to finally be himself the kilowatt held
back by illumi's needle
was caught in darkness outshone by gone
slides
once it was removed however kilo
approved in every way
to be the one shining by far the
brightest in their friendship from that
point onwards
while gon removes himself from all his
friends around him more and more after
kite's death
kiluah forms countless new relationships
over the course of the chimera and arc
and this goes so far that he even
befriends one of the ants itself
being part of the enemy icalgo would
have straightforwardly been killed if
this was hunter x and kilua
operating under the standard practices
of the family business
however at this point kilua has
developed such a strong sense of
morality
compassion and nuanced decision making
that he understands the anne's complex
situation
and ultimately saves him exactly the
development that gone
failed to make in this arc as a result
kiluah not only makes a friend
but his kindness is repaid almost
immediately when he calgo saves him
after an unsettlingly dangerous game of
darts
and i think the growth he undergoes in
this arc is even reflected in his
fighting
when kilowatt unveils his ultimate hatsu
technique godspeed on up
who previously was way way stronger than
him it is a striking sign of just
how much his character and thus also his
skills have grown
[Music]
while it's true that kilua was always a
prodigy able to learn new skills way
faster than normal
and that his cruel childhood gave him a
physical advantage in other ways
it was his journey with gone and
ultimately his
own innate will and humanity that
enabled one of my favorite character
arcs
in general and so with the end of the
chimera and arc
kilua has finally found his sense of
self-worth and his free will
the only things left for his arc were
breaking fully free from his family
and finding a purpose in life and
ironically enough
once again it's gone who enables this
change
being on the verge of death after his
inhuman transformation
killua travels home to ask his little
sister aluka
and the something living inside her to
heal god's wounds
fittingly to their opposed character
arcs kilua is the main protagonist of
this last arc in the story
being a much more relatable hero than
gon was towards the end
freeing and traveling with his sister
kiluah finally realizes that she is his
new purpose in life
and that he can be for alooka and nanika
what gun was for him
a light in the darkness
and so at the end of his arc when he
parts ways with gon to travel with his
sister
kilua has finally found what god has
lost
his humanity and similar to gone his
character arc has
basically found a complete end at this
point so
should kilua ever return to the story he
will need a new character arc as well
the powerful message that togashi is
sending with this character here
is that you're not bound by your
upbringing but have the freedom to forge
your own path
and that morality and humanity are
something that can bloom
even under the harshest circumstances
so now that we've discussed the
mirroring structure of gon's extreme
negative
and kilowatt's extreme positive arc i
think in the next video i want to
discuss a character
with a flat character arc it is one of
the most iconic figures in anime manga
and for a very good reason often used as
the face of the series
[Music]
i'm of course talking about hisoka and
one of the most creative antagonists i
know
so stay tuned for that okay wow
i've been rambling forever now thanks
guys
peace